[Music]
probably one of my most favorite places
I think in the entire world it is the
most beautiful ranch there's over 4,000
acres and they have shot so many films
here I'm pretty sure you guys have seen
so many of them we also did a really
amazing tour here back in October I
never posted that vlog but today you're
finally gonna get to see it the first
we're going to hop on this boat and go a
little small tiny cool island so guys
one thing that I definitely recommend
you should never drone from a moving
boat it's a really bad idea so
thankfully we're not moving I mean it's
definitely possible
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm about to attempt a really fun drone
shot I basically want to fly it through
this little boat and up and away so
let's hope that it works on try to I'm
gonna do one basing me
[Music]
they filmed rasp Park here they film so
many movies and we're going to go to all
of his locations and check them out so
let's go we've got to go rally the
troops we are here with our family and
our friend Susie and I don't know where
Bree went she's somewhere
[Music]
I'll pride everybody hot guys in the
front
yes this was great
[Music]
[Music]
this is where Jurassic world was filmed
and the helicopter that took off in the
beginning was actually right here but
they dismantled it because they didn't
want actual helicopters to land here
inside of the ranch the visitors center
was brought in all by CGI's basically
this was a canvas for them to start with
and the rest of it was all filled in
with CGI this is probably my favorite
part so far of the tour this is where
the t-rex escaped at the beginning of
the movie and they said that normally on
movie sets they end up taking down all
of the props and things like that but
this they left up because it was a very
highly requested thing that people
wanted to see on the tour this is so
cool look out behind us we're gonna go
up there right now but they said that
they're doing some construction on the
glass because all of this stuff had to
sort of be remade because originally
when things are created for movies
they're all tore down because they're
not built to last
especially in Hawaiian tropical
conditions like this we're going up look
here it is this is so cool I'm freaking
out the ice is so excited
not sure which genesis hmmm updated I
was 11 and the photobooth app
[Music]
behind me is the restaurant where they
filmed for 50 first dates with Adam
Sandler and Drew Barrymore I've got some
popcorn here it's snack time and break
on the tour but this is so pretty like
it is awesome so this here right here is
where they dock the submarine and loss
[Music]
q
this is such an awesome view
[Music]
right here is Hurley's golf course from
lost if you guys remember that from the
show any lost fans god I love that show
those are Eric on Philips footsteps here
pretty huge now that I'm up close to it
it just kind of looks like a big dirt
hole you would never be able to tell
this business of what's that well this
is a pretty cool view
[Music]
this is from calm small island I never
saw the movie so I'm not really sure it
was this is in reference to but now I'm
gonna have to see it and then I'll be
able to be like wow we were there
there should be a shrine nearby
[Music]
we're now heading into the world war two
bunkers which is also doubled as some
scenes for lost oh here it is the lost
looking for anyway now that I'm not as
terrified as I was before
[Music]
Oh guys thank you so much for watching
this vlog that was basically it seems
like almost six months in the making I
love this place and if you guys are ever
in a Wahoo I definitely recommend you
have to check it out it is just
incredibly breathtaking the views the
scenery and all the people here are so
nice it's such an experience that I hope
that one day you guys can also
experience it to spit out that's it
let's do the vlog I'll see you guys
later
[Music]
[Music]